INTERVIEWER: This
is a satellite image
of Porong, Indonesia in 2004.
This is that same place in 2008.
What happened in
between those two photos
wasn't an earthquake
or a typhoon.
It was one of the most
mysterious natural disasters
in memory, and actually it might
not have been natural at all.
On May 29, 2006, vast
quantities of mud
began bubbling up out of a
gas and oil field in Porong.
The flow blossomed
into a full on mud
volcano, which is actually
a scientific term.
It might not sound as scary
as a volcano spewing lava,
but the mud spread quickly
and disastrously, completely
overwhelming 12
separate villages
in the area and displacing
ten of thousands of people.
Now there are few
very important things
to say about this event, which
is called the Lapindo Mud
Flow, or Lusi for short.
Firstly, it's the largest
mud volcano in the world.
At its peak output, Lusi
exuded 180,000 cubic meters
of mud every day, which
is enough to fill about
75 Olympic swimming pools.
Secondly, it's still very
much active, almost 10 years
after the first eruption.
No one knows how long the
mud will keep flowing,
but many experts predict
another two decades worth.
Faced with that prognosis,
locals in the area
are doing their best
to live alongside Lusi.
They've built levees to keep
the mud out of populated areas.
And with few other industries
available for work,
some have turned to
a form of tourism.
It's not huge business,
but lots of Indonesians
are curious to see
firsthand what they'd
heard about in the media.
[SPEAKING INDONESIAN]
INTERPRETER: I had watched a
lot of the news on television,
but I didn't expect that
seeing it with my own eyes
could give such a different
impression, as I imagine
about 13 villages underneath
the mud, and it stills bursting.
If this is called terrorism, I
suppose this is tragic tourism.
INTERVIEWER: There's one other
thing about the Lusi disaster
that still has
people up in arms.
No one's quite sure whether
people are to blame for it.
Two days before the eruption,
a 6.3 magnitude earthquake
struck the region,
and initially experts
believed that to be the
trigger for the mud flow.
But other studies
have since argued
that the blame lies with
the oil and gas drilling
at the site of the eruption.
Courts in Indonesia have ruled
that the gas company, Lapindo
Brantas, was not at fault,
though the company has still
paid out millions in
compensation to the community.
They've also tried and failed
to plug up the mud flow.
One exasperated engineer
describe the volcano
as being simply
impossible to kill.
Today, nine years later,
the mud is still flowing.
The people of Porong
haven't forgotten
the loss of their villages,
nor the possible involvement
of Lapindo Brantas.
They've staged some
protests in commemoration
at the site of the
accident, and they've
erected some permanent art
installations there too.
One represents those
displaced by the mud,
and another, more pointedly,
features an effigy
of the mining companies
owner, alongside a stone tomb,
bearing the words let
this nation not forget.
Hey everyone.
If you're looking
for secret stories,
check out this next episode
about a town in Russia
that the government kept hidden
from the world for years.
It's been more than two decades
since the Soviet era ended.
Russia and its people
have moved on--
well, except for
towns like this.
SUBJECT: Zarechny.
It's former name was Penza-19.
INTERVIEWER: And as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.